Heute geht es um Artikel 0 des Grundgesetzes:
Freie Fahrt für freie Bürger.
In Absatz (1) heißt es:
Die Würde des Autofahrers ist unantastbar.
Er hat das Recht auf freie Entfaltung seiner
Fahrzeugführungspersönlichkeit.
Absatz (2) 300 km/h auf der Autobahn sind mein
gutes Recht, ich hab noch nen Termin.
Absatz (3) Brummbrummbrumm.
Deutschland hat kein Tempolimit auf seinen
Autobahnen und ist damit in bester Gesellschaft.
Machen wir ein Quiz!!!!!
Welche Länder verzichten noch auf ein Tempolimit
auf Autobahnen?
Richtig!
Afghanistan, Somalia, Nordkorea!
Und Deutschland.
Das Quartett der Verkehrsterrorstaaten ist
damit komplett.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen übertrieben, die
deutsche Verkehrspolitik als Terrorismus
zu bezeichnen?
Seit 1950 sind in Deutschland 780.000 Menschen
gewaltsam im Straßenverkehr umgekommen.
Das sind mehr Menschen, als Frankfurt am Main
Einwohner hat.
Freie Fahrt für Freie Bürger ist ein Heiligtum,
die Angst der Politik vor Veränderung ist riesig:
Bei einem Tempolimit werden wir alle sterben!
Dabei ist es eher umgekehrt.
Je schneller ein Auto auf der Autobahn unterwegs
ist, desto wahrscheinlicher ist es,
dass ein Unfall tödlich endet.
Wir gucken uns das mal kurz an:
Ein Auto fährt auf der Autobahn, plötzlich
ist etwas ist im Weg.
Ein Kaninchen!
Nein, ein Baby!
Nein, sechs Babykaninchen!
Mit Warnwesten!
Sonst kann man die aus der Entfernung nicht
erkennen.
Also Vollbremsung!
Wenn das Auto nur 80 km/h fährt, steht es
bereits nach 88 Metern.
Wenn es 130 km/h fährt, nach 208 Metern
Bei 180 km/h sind es 378 Meter Bremsweg
Und bei 230 km/h …
Je langsamer man fährt, desto schneller steht
man.
Das ist logisch.
Wenn man zum Beispiel 0 km/h fährt, steht
man schon.
Ok, den nehmen wir raus, der war sogar mir
zu schlecht.
Ohne Tempolimit sterben mehr Menschen.
Trotzdem gilt auf 60 % der deutschen Autobahnen
kein Tempolimit.
Was den Amerikanern ihre Waffen, ist den Deutschen
die Freie Fahrt auf der Autobahn .
Wenn ein Auto auf einen Menschen trifft, ist
das Auto eine Waffe.
In Ländern wie Frankreich oder Österreich
gibt es ein Tempolimit von 130 km/h,
in Belgien darf man auf der Autobahn höchstens
120 km/h fahren.
Da ist doch die Frage: Warum hassen diese
Länder ihre Bürger so?
Die Autoindustrie ist sowas die deutsche NRA.
Obwohl die Fakten offenkundig sind und keine
andere Industrienation der Welt so einen Unsinn
macht, ist die Politik ohnmächtig.
Da hat die Autobranche natürlich Recht!
Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungen gefährden Arbeitsplätze in der Automobilindustrie.
Je schneller man fahren darf, desto mehr Autounfälle
gibt es,
desto mehr Autos können verkauft werden.
So gesehen gefährdet das Tempolimit auch
Arbeitsplätze in der Versicherungsbranche,
Gesundheitsbranche, Bestattungsbranche, Seelsorge.
Die 30er-Zone ist ein
volkswirtschaftliches Fiasko.
Der damalige Verkehrsminister Dobrindt meinte
2015: „Zur Wahrheit gehört leider auch dazu,
dass notorische Raser sich nicht von
Tempolimits abschrecken lassen“
Wer kennt sie nicht, diese Argumentation:
Weil sich Menschen nicht an Regeln halten,
stellen wir sie gar nicht erst auf.
Ich erinnere mich an weitere Zitate von Dobrindt:
„Zur Wahrheit gehört leider auch, dass
sich Mörder nicht von Gefängnisstrafen
abschrecken lassen.“
Deswegen ist Mord in Deutschland erlaubt.
Wer 250 km/h fährt, bedroht andere Menschen
mit dem Tod.
Der Staat schaut zu.
Vor, zurück.
Cool, uncool.
Sind Sie für ein Tempolimit oder wollen Sie,
dass diese sechs Babykaninchen sterben?